good evening everyone
members I will now proceed to read out
the emergency evacuation announcement
there are no planned fire drills so if
the alarm activates please leave the
building in Northerly fashion via your
nearest fire exit the fire exits are
through the two partition doors to each
side of the hall and through the main
doors of the hall or the storeroom
adjacent to the stage
the fire assembly point is the
roundabout Island in front of the main
entrance to the building
please do not delayed your evacuation to
collect any belongings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by Council staff
please know that this meeting will be
audio recorded
please switch off mobiles or turn them
to silent
toilets and hand washing facilities are
available in the foyer area
committee
members there is a need to use
microphones during the meeting when I
invite you to speak please wait until
there's a microphone in front of you
before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing Loop and also for
the audio recording
they are all switched on and ready for
you to speak so you do not need to
adjust them
please make sure the microphone is
directly in front of you before speaking
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution I
will ask for a show of hands
four
then against recommendations
and finally I will ask for show of hands
from those abstaining from voting
so agenda item number one apologies for
absence
members we have received apologies from
councilors sharp and councilor Wilson
councilor Mrs Lisa Newport and councilor
James Newport are there any other
apologies
none
members uh councilor Stanley will
substitute for councilor Sharp
agenda item 3 non-members attending
we have counselor Mr FD attending this
meeting
agenda item number four minutes of the
meeting held on the 8th of November are
the minutes agreed members
thank you
gender item number five
are there any Declarations of membership
uh sorry of Interest please members
none thank you
gender item six
it's the
2022-23 mid-year treasury management
review
members Naomi Lucas the assistant
director for resources will present the
officer's report
thank you chair and yeah the purpose of
this report is to provide an update of
the council's treasury management
activity for the period 1st of April
2022 to 30th of September 2022 in
accordance with the council's treasury
management policy in good practice
um it's recommended that members of this
committee note the activities during
this period and provide any comments or
questions on the information before it's
presented back to full Council on the
13th of December
so members will note section three
there's an economic update which sets
out the the current economic position
and also some interest rate forecasts
um provided to us by our treasury
management Consultants link
um section four sets out
um any changes to the capital and
treasury strategy of which there have
not been any
um and section five sets out the um kind
of Prudential indicators that were
required to report on throughout the
year
um so if you
turn your attention to the table at the
paragraph 5.1 on page 6.4 of your
reports at the top you'll note that the
capital expenditure for the council for
this year has the forecast has dropped
from
um just under 5.7 million to about 4.3
million the main reason for that is the
delay to the asset delivery program
which is now not expected to
proceed in terms of capital expenditure
during this financial year and there's
therefore been a corresponding reduction
in the capital financing required and
members will note that that is was
mainly due to be funded from the hard
soft infrastructure Reserve which is why
that that um that number has reduced
from one point just under 1.5 million to
zero
um paragraph 5.2 just confirms that the
council um does not have any external
borrowing this has been the case
um
and yeah we just confirmed that there's
no change to the authorized operational
limits in terms of our treasury
management
so if I just turn quickly to section six
of the reports are the council's
Investment Portfolio
so your notes at paragraph 6.2 that the
balance of Investments held by the
council at the beginning of the year was
22 million pounds plus just under 5
million in our current accounts there's
been various
um sort of short-term transactions
during the first six months of the year
in terms of short-term Investments that
we place and then bring back to manage
our cash flow but the overall position
for the council has not changed
materially so at the 30th of September
we were holding 23.5 million in
Investments and just under a million in
our current account
um and that's just shown kind of
graphically at the table at 6.3
[Music]
so at the 30th of September the table at
6.4 just gives a breakdown of where
those
um
short-term monies were being held
um
so you can see that they were mainly
being held in our Santander current
account sorry not a current account um
our 95 day accounts and also in um money
market funds um predominantly
um so I just bring some members
attention the fact that we didn't
actually budget for any interest and
this year and that's because when we set
the budget back in February
um interest rates were at some historic
low and we were earning virtually
nothing on our Investment Portfolio
however
um your notes obviously from the news
and the change the economic forecast the
interest rates have been rising and
fairly rapidly over the last six months
so we're now forecasting an investment
return for the year of around 225 000
pounds
um and we just note in the investment
performance table
um the rates that the council's
achieving compared to the Benchmark that
our treasury advisors link
um have kind of indicated would be an
average return
um across um The Wider sector so you can
see that we're we continue to sort of
outperform
um on our investments compared to the to
the wider sector
um I would also just quickly like to
draw your attention to paragraph 6.6
where already note that
um
we set our own
um sort of internal limits um to hold
our cash balances and our current
Accounts at five million pounds normally
that is just an internal limit and is
just intended to ensure that we don't um
hold sort of vast amounts of cash in our
current account
um or that being said it obviously is
um a
um an internally set limit that we put
in our treasury strategy and there was
one occasion um during this six-month
period where we did temporarily
temporarily go over that five million
pound limit
um for a day and that was just as a
result of um human error where a a
drawback of cash wasn't processed um
properly on the system but that was
corrected immediately that it was um
realized and there's no wider
ramifications of that but obviously um
just want to be transparent and pointing
that point that out
um so I think that's the
main points I'd like to
um sort of cover if anyone's got any
questions happy to try and answer them
thank you thank you Naomi um members
have you got any questions for Naomi
um councilor Mrs Garrison
can you hear me okay yeah thank you
um
I think you answered the first question
that I was going to ask was about the
hard soft infrastructure reserves
um could you just on um page 6.5 and the
graph
um just below 6.2 I just could you just
explain the figures where it goes from
22 million to 43 42 and then to 23.
yeah so
as I said that the starting balance of
22 million pounds
um yeah is what we're holding the first
of April
um the 43 and a half and 42 kind of um I
suppose could be a bit hard to
understand but it's basically the
cumulative impact of where we've
invested
um
smaller amounts just for cash flow
purposes so we might um on a day-to-day
basis invest five million and then draw
it back a few days later and you know
invest two million and then draw that
back a few days later so the 43 and a
half million
um is the kind of the cumulative impact
of all those smaller Investments
um that you'll see that the
corresponding figure in terms of this
amount we bought back of 42 million is
nearly the same figure so it's it's
really just um as I say the kind of
short-term comings and goings in terms
of cash flow management it's not
actually amounts are invested
um you know for any particular wider
purpose it is just to to make sure we've
got the cash we need on a day-to-day
basis right okay sorry did you did you
explain that no no sorry I just
mentioned the starting and opening
balances yeah okay and
um
hello the investment figures
um obviously the interest rates
are in our favor at the moment and the
way that the money is invested
um when we look at the interest earned
on our three months Investments
um
I would assume but through those amounts
that we have well clearly we have quite
Less in the three-month Investments but
they're making a very good return I'm
just wondering
um is the movement to put more money in
the longer term investments to get a
better return
um
yeah well our primary objective is to
ensure liquidity so we've got the right
amounts when we need it so
um we tend to do
um shorter term investments just so that
we can bring the cash back when we need
it
um yeah we we haven't got the ability
under our client strategy to invest for
more than
um a year but yeah there is the
potential
um to sometimes invest for slightly
longer periods of three to six months
um it just it just really depends on
um yeah the availability of kind of
certain products and um yeah what we
need at a particular time so there's no
particular reason why we shouldn't lock
up a bit more for a slightly longer
periods but
um yeah our current strategy doesn't
allow us to invest more than 12 months
at the moment can I just ask is that a
strategy regularly reviewed I mean
especially in light of the interest
rates
at the moment yeah so the strategy is
brought so the strategy is brought to
this committee every year
um and then to full Council as part of
the budget and setting so
um yeah we haven't fundamentally changed
the strategy in the last few years but
um I suppose there is the potential if
um members of the committee wanted to
that I suppose you could ask for us to
look into that um
specifically in a bit more detail
obviously if we're holding significant
cash balances there is potentially the
opportunity to
um yeah hold Investments for a bit
longer and earn a bit more interest
um I suppose what we haven't
traditionally had as a council is a lot
of long-term certainty over our planning
in terms of what our Capital
um kind of expenditure requirements
would be or you know um so before you
lock up a lot of money for a long time
you need to be certain that you're not
going to need it back you know for in 12
months so I think it's just having that
long-term Financial forecasting
um kind of position that you'll you know
when you're likely to need those monies
back and then you can make informed
choices about how long you invest for
but it's certainly something that could
be we can be considered as part
structure so thank you
thank you um are there any more
questions uh councilor Mr Mill
let's go get this over it's more of a
general question we we noted that um
there are acronyms and reports and terms
which the public are not too familiar
and we would wonder if we could suggest
or recommend that an appendix list
listing acronyms and terms could be
added
to these reports just for clarity really
and I think once it's been set up
because a lot of the terms get repeated
it wouldn't be too much work to keep it
up
yeah I think yeah take that more than um
yeah I've um
I'll link with my um Team to try and
ensure that we have that in the future
thank you
hi we um we pay consultants for their
advice that they give us on our
investments
um
do we know what the average fees are
over the year and I'll be getting value
for money from those fees
yeah um so I think this is a question we
have almost every committee and I think
I've answered them sort of several times
in the past but yeah we obviously do go
out to procurement in terms of our
treasury advisors and we put here
through a framework so we're relatively
comfortable that we you know achieve
value for money I mean in terms of
benchmarking against what others pay
um it really depends on the complexity
of the advice that you need obviously
we're a fairly small Council and we
don't have much complexity around our
investments we don't have any boring but
for other you know bigger authorities
with much more diverse kind of
investment in borrowing portfolios and
the sort of level advice they would need
would be probably significantly more so
it's hard to kind of get a true like for
like but yeah we definitely make sure
that we try and Achieve value for money
through
um using a procurement framework so do
we have a an app do we have an average
costing that they charge us on a is it a
yearly basis or a monthly basis
um yeah it's a three it's we've uh
procure I think for three years at a
time and it's a fixed um annual
rate or it might go I can't remember if
it goes up by inflation each year um I
did have the number and I think have
reported it before I can't remember it
offhand but I can I can email it around
to the committee afterwards if you like
no me
thank you councilor Stanley
I've got one here thanks uh Naomi
um a lot of uh businesses that have
quite a few million Investments
um I've noticed that they they do have
somebody that is a day-to-day
uh accountant if you like that works on
interest rates and where best to get
their profits from
do we have such an officer in the
council that can do this or is it
something that the council may be
looking forward to in the future
um with that one some sound too flipper
and we've got a very small team and um I
don't think the complexity of the um
Investments as we've um said would
warrant certainly weren't a full-time
post at Rochford
um we have a very small team and we've
got certain people in the team that are
um if you like kind of specialists in
need on this air and they've got a bit
more expertise but we obviously have to
have a bit of resilience in terms of
other members of the team being able to
cover it so
um yeah I suppose the short answer is no
not proposing to have a you know a
singular person
um sort of primarily focused on on on
this stuff at the moment because I don't
feel it's warranted obviously if the
situation of the council was to change
significantly that's maybe something we
can reconsider
thank you Naomi to the answer thank you
any more questions please members
thank you then if I can um please
members there is one recommendation on
paragraph 11 on page 6.7 of the report
that the contents of this treasury
mid-year report be recommended for
Council can those members in favor
please raise their hands
thank you members that is unanimous
um just uh would like members to know
that he is actually Naomi's last
overview in scrutiny committee meeting
with us before she leaves the council so
I think everybody will echo my words and
we thank you sincerely Naomi for all
your hard work I think you've had some
grillings upon times and dealt with them
superbly so good luck in the future and
uh thank you I think we'd love to live
here thanks
[Applause]
thank you members um Now we move on to
agenda item seven which is the
regulation of investor
Gatorade Powers Act 2000 Ripper
um
members uh Tracy liller's director of
four communities and health will
introduce the officer's report
thank you
um that's better apologies for my
likeness I was in South Street doing the
cost of living webinar but as members
will know that the purpose of the report
is just really to update you on the use
of Rita over the past year which is zero
we don't use it we haven't used it since
2011 and that's quite right actually
because Ripper for those of you that
don't know is is targeted surveillance
which is not something that we as a
local Authority should be doing we can
cover everything that we need to do in
our powers now Realm by the powers
available to us already covert
surveillance is really around police
investigations and the intelligence
Community but I'm happy to answer any
questions that any members may have oh
and hands gone up already
dope too
thank you Tracy uh members um councilor
Myers
good evening just a quick question
um up until 2004 when my late wife died
she was employed by Brentwood Council as
a benefit fraud investigator
ER and her partner Carol on a regular
basis probably once a week applied for
Ripper authorizations to check people
claiming benefit but they were saying
they were living alone and they would
sit up outside the house just to make
sure there was no one going in out so do
Rochford District Council have nothing
to check this sort of behavior I mean
it's on two there's two questions really
why does Rochford not bother
investigating this type of benefit fraud
and if they are investigating it are
they doing it unlawfully outside of the
River Act
I can answer that for you
um in terms of
Rochford currently anything around
housing benefit or Universal Credit is
investigated by the DWP so the
department of work and pensions and that
has been the case since 2017 so it is
investigated it's just investigated by a
different organization we carry out some
preliminary
investigations and we have officers that
do that but the actual intrusive element
of the investigation is undertaken by
the department of work and pensions
and to answer your question
thank you uh councilor Mrs gatter sorry
on a similar vein
um how do you resolve if you've got
someone
um seeking accommodation and
um they or part of the family's housed
and then they are not actually living in
the accommodation so they're using the
temporary premises to get permanent
accommodation and so if I have a
resident that comes to me and says but
he's not living there because and his
family's somewhere else how does that
get investigated
that's a difficult one for me to answer
because that sits within housing but it
still wouldn't be something that we
would use Ripper for because it's very
that the restrictions around Ripper are
very stringent so like I said it's it's
targeted surveillance on an individual
and it's quite intensive and it has to
be and this is where the caveat is which
I think might be helpful for members in
order to undertake Ripper the offense
has to be indictable by at least a
six-month jail sentence
so that's the caveat so before you can
even consider undertaking surveillance
the the offense that you're
investigating has to be punishable by at
least six months in prison
so it's it's a really good point and I
think that's some of the kind of
misunderstanding around Ripper and why
we don't use it it's not because we
don't want to we're very keen on
preventing all the kind of things you
know the fraud and everything else that
goes on but actually we've got some
powers that we can do and there's lots
of things the fraud team can do in terms
of checking out finances and things like
that but actually targeted surveillance
which is watching an individual is very
stringent and usually for the police to
undertake that I hope that
yes it just leaves me a little bit
unclear about how the council does deal
with people that are using accommodation
in that way do you do you have a
supplementary question Mrs getson
how does the council deal with um
fraudulent use of housing
putting my housing hat on
um because I used to be director of
housing for Brentwood there's a number
of ways that we would investigate it and
we would carry out
interviews with residents and check
um kind of the setup with the family but
in terms of actually
surveillance we wouldn't undertake that
and there are a number of ways that you
can do it but I don't and the honest
answer is I don't know how Roch would
undertake that here because you don't
have a housing stock
so you know you've only got housing
needs and homelessness so it's slightly
different so I don't want to put work
their way or say something incorrect but
I can answer that through the housing
team for From rochford's perspective
thank you
thank you um councilor Milne uh yeah my
question is is is is is not actually
directly related to Ripper but it is
directed to resources and deterring
offenses now you can look at an area not
an individual yeah if you have equipment
and resources and I'm particularly
looking at fly tipping I mean this area
I I'm rather surprised we haven't had
more trouble because it's kind of wide
open like a wild west because they can
come breezing in and dump things
anywhere
we're not known to be using cameras to
look at known flight tipping sites and
it must affect people in the environment
section of the council and cost us money
the fines that are actually probably uh
less than the money Recovery and it
isn't cleaning up
so that this kind of area uh and the
anti-social Behavior we're looking at
areas not looking at people so we're not
looking at a directed or intrusive
surveillance
so I'm into all this because I should be
an intelligence desk manager in the net
you see because we use this stuff and
that also um so that this kind of
resourcing now we're in with Brentwood
is there any chance we might be able to
get some kind of capability
and then the news gets out there's
probably bad news to tip in Rochford
um that was
that's the first question the other
thing is anti-social Behavior graffitis
and all those kind of things get
reported and again we're looking at area
not individuals and it's more of a
passive evidence generator but then I
know the police can do it but I could
well imagine they probably won't bother
because they've got other things to do
you know there's a problem so they're
the two things to do resourcing and to
do that kind of of approach and
uh finally the last thing is who are our
liaison officers with the DWP and I know
we've got community safety with the
police who are all right there and
perhaps with even hmrc whoever's
involved you know because you're
obviously using those bodies and not
getting involved in yourself so I know
there's a few things there but it's
mainly the area
coverage not the individual no I'll do
my best to answer because you've you've
poked a bear because Community safety is
my passion and fly tipping is a Scourge
on communities quite frankly
um I'm very careful when I'm here as a
Rochford officer that I don't come in
and say we do this in Brentwood but one
of the things we are lucky with in
Brentwood is that we do have a team so
what I can assure members is that I'm
looking at a review service review of
the offer if you like around Community
safety one thing I would say is fly
tipping sits with me in Brentwood it
doesn't sit with me in watchford that
may change but what I can assure members
is we do in watchford use cameras for
fly tip and we just put out posters and
stuff just to let people know it's a
really difficult one and I'm I'm very
upfront and honest you'll get to know me
as time goes on love me or hate me I
don't think cameras are necessarily the
answer and I'll give you a really really
brief good example because I get far too
excited because I have no life we work
with an organization called National
enforcement Solutions who I'm hoping to
bring over to Rochford and I'll give you
a bit more detail about that in a moment
but they we use some of their cameras
and they're quite well hidden and we're
very lucky in Brentwood that we've got
signs out already because we have CCTV
so we it wasn't covert surveillance it's
just targeting an area as you say and a
vehicle turned up very identifiable
wonderful number plate gentleman gets
out clear view of his face I literally
jumped in the office and I don't move
about that much with excitement because
I thought we've got him bang to rights
it turned out to be a cloned vehicle
and it was a completely innocent person
and we never identified the individual
so what I would say to people is CCTV
has its place but Community intelligence
is the key and what we do in in
Brentwood and I'm hoping to kind of
replicate that over here is that our
offices will go out they will
investigate a fly tip and we will go
through a pile and another example like
I love a live example
I was out on patrol with the police a
few moons back and a vehicle went past
with loads of Hardcore on it quite late
at night so the police pulled it over
and they said oh we're just doing some
work up the road you know so so I said
well where's your waste carry license oh
I don't have it on me well you need to
have it on you you need to produce it he
said well I'm going to this site I said
okay well that's fine well I'll check
that site in the morning and I went back
to the address with the officers that
were with me knocked on the gentleman's
door and he one of the sheepishly opened
the door and said I'm gonna help you and
I said you've just had your driveway
done and he said yes that's correct I
said we've just pulled the vehicle up
down the road with all your hardcore on
the back
um did you check they had a waste
carrier license
and he said well no I didn't think that
was my responsibility I said it is and
unfortunately we're now going to issue
with a 700 pound fine because it's a
duty of care so there's all more than
one way to skin a cat as I say so it's
about being proactive around it working
with the community
having that Community intelligence one
of the things we do and I'm hoping again
to bring it over here without and
developing in a different way because it
will look differently for Rockford than
it does for Brentwood but we have weekly
tasking so we look at Hot Spot areas
emerging Trends issues that we need to
address and we target those areas with
our partners accordingly so that's
something that we'll look to bring in as
we move on in terms of community safety
again you've got one part-time Community
safety manager here you don't have a
housing stock so that's slightly
different we have a bigger team in
Brentwood
and I'm hoping like I said through the
service review to look at the offer that
we give because for for little money I
mean there's a bit of money involved but
for little money you can actually do an
awful lot and it's around working in
Partnerships that's the key and it
always has been and and sometimes that's
a frustration because we work really
well with our partners but sometimes
internally we don't work so well but um
I'm really passionate about Community
safety fly tipping particularly but what
I would say before I came this evening I
just double checked and in terms of fly
tipping for 20 122 there were 410 in
this District which is significantly
less than we experiencing in another
area of Essex but we've issued 15 early
warning letters and nine fpns for litter
and six for fly tip in just to kind of
give you some example of how that could
improve if we work alongside National
enforcement Solutions in Brentwood we
were no different one year we issued 11
oven fixed penalty notices
when we took on National enforcement
Solutions last year we issued 1400 over
1400. and that was an income of ten
thousand pounds so it's a cost neutral
service to us there's a bit of bedding
in I will say because people don't like
to be told they've just dropped some
litter but my view is if you don't drop
the litter you won't get in trouble so
um yeah I don't there was a third
question but like I said I've gone off
on a tangent of my passion and I've lost
train of thought
because because of the partnership with
Brentwood and transferring across that
was what that was about so that's
already done yeah I mean that's the
passion of mine to make sure that this
partnership works for both sides so it's
not about what Brentwood can do for
Rochester that's not that tall but
actually there's some joint similarities
that we can do in resilience building is
more I'd like to say thank you thank you
uh councilor Hayes
thank you chair
um Tracy thank you uh very much for the
explanation so far if I hear right your
explanation of use of Ripper Powers is
basically on uh one-to-one
um
uh observation and recording
what I'm hearing tonight is that there
is nothing that Rochford is doing that
comes under Ripper
so is there anything
that Rochford is doing or planning to do
that actually comes under Ripper at all
I'm just wondering I'll be honest I'm
wondering if we're wasting our time
it's a loaded question I'm not going to
say about you wasting your time but I I
did I don't do anything similar to this
in Brentwood and it is we shouldn't be
what there's checks and balances to go
through before you ever consider using a
ripper Authority and I can't see us as a
local Authority ever get into that point
where we would need to do that we have
to have obviously systems in place and
policies in place and that's absolutely
fine one of the things that I can do is
I am very lucky in having an officer in
Brentwood that's very experienced around
CCTV and Ripper and he very kindly or
stupidly
said that he's more than happy to be
contacted by any member to discuss any
concerns or questions that members might
have around CCTV or Ripper and I happily
provide his contact details thank you so
there's nothing that we're in Rochford
involved no okay thank you thank you
Tracey are your questions answered
councilories
thank you thank you thank you uh
councilor Stanley
thank you chairman
um I do really do believe that Tracy
does know what I'm going to come up with
in a minute
whereas we have got see what we're about
to have CCTV and lots of District
Council are part of that partnership
with RTC and Ripa may come into their
domain sooner than what they think once
this CCTV comes into effect
there are other aspects which might be
added to which might involve Ripper
we're just discussing that at the moment
and I may put that to RTC to get in
touch with that person if you could let
me know who he is and give us that
information I thank you for that my
other concern is that as we are
concerned about rubbish we should also
be concerned about our Community Health
and you know where I'm going on this one
I'm sure is there with this new
incentive that we've got with these
people that you're talking about would
they be able to make any head Headway in
that
position that we're in at the moment
where we are waiting for the environment
agency to act upon
um
it's imperative obviously that this
needs to be sorted out once and for all
as we've got a law breaker I believe to
be a law breaker I'm not mentioning who
he is but I believe so and we should be
helping our community
with their health as well as the
community we we have that information
and where do we is that possible for
those people to help us with this
situation I'll try and answer that in
general terms rather than specific terms
in terms of RTC and our CCTV that's a
tongue twister Jonathan woodhams is the
officer and he's actually been in
contact with I think it's the Clark RTC
around supporting the work that they're
doing around CCTV
in terms of the other issue it's similar
thing to Ripper and it's a massive
frustration of mine because it looks
like as officers we're putting up
barriers but it's not we have to act
within the legislation we have available
to us and unfortunately
um if people want to say for example
have bonfires that's not illegal in
order for us to prove it's a statutory
nuisance it's really difficult and
really challenging but we as officers a
qualified officer has to witness it to
be able to assess whether it is a
statutory nuisance or not so bonfires
themselves are not illegal the statutory
nuisance element is why you need the
qualified officer because they are
cross-examined by the through the courts
when we take cases to court and what I
would say is we've had two well we've
got one that's gone through the courts
very successfully and another that is
the case has just been put before the
call so we are proactive when we can and
when we can witness it the difficulty is
witnessing it and I absolutely agree
with you you know we do need to be as
proactive as we can but as Naomi alluded
to we've only got a very you know short
number of staff and we've got offices
going above and beyond
try and witness it so it's a difficult
one but we carry on we don't give up
thank you just answer your question
Council I'd just like to come back
Germany if I may
um is there any way that we could use
cameras or some sort of um radio
communication so that when I and the
action appears that that communication
is dealt with in in that time period is
there any way forward on that in the way
of communication
we can't use cameras because it's the
same for in terms of photos being taken
it doesn't necessarily prove a statutory
nuisance because there's all kinds and
I'm not going to get into it now but
there's all kinds of wheels of smoke and
the color and everything else so and in
terms of being available officers you
know have made themselves available out
of hours and I think the current officer
is investigating a matter where he's
given his own mobile number so that he
can be on court when he's on call he can
go out there that's as best we can give
if I'm being honest I would I would pull
back from that but I'm aware that you
know our residents are suffering so we
need to do as much as we can but we need
to be mindful that we've got a very
limited number of staff that can be on
call 24 7. thank you thank you Jim thank
you councilor Mrs good in
good evening it's actually a pleasure to
hear the answers that you was given on
councilor milne's points because just
this week alone I've reported more than
four flight tippings this week so it's a
particular bug bear within the district
and I I run a group that has a
significant amount of people that report
into me to report to the council so
that's an ongoing thing so the national
enforcement Solutions is something that
like you say is self-sustainable should
have happened ages ago I know we've got
one part-time officer that you know
isn't able to be there Johnny on the
spot all the time but I hope we can get
this resolved so I'm really looking
forward to what you can bring to the
council thank you oh it's nice to be
told that my answers are a landing well
what I would say about the national
enforcement Solutions is there is some
pain to be had because like I said they
will go out there and they will start
issuing tickets for people that are
littering that have never had that
before
so we did have some pain to go through
but it's really nice to hear that
members are supportive of that thank you
thank you councilor constable
two points did they
if they go around
um checking on litter perhaps if they
follow our dustbins and it all fallen
out of the bag of the Dustbin lorridge
they can sort that one out but on page
7.23 he's got the Ripper monitor officer
he's Angela law has that been replaced
has she been replaced now and who is the
new going to be the new Ripper
monitoring officer
yes
um unfortunately we've had a number of
Staff leaving us at the moment so we do
have an interim
um officer that's come in and I'm just
for the life of me trying to remember
his name it's Andrew
honkin thank you very much so yes she
has been replaced by an interim at the
present stage so yeah that has happened
thank you to sound your question thank
you counselor Sandy you want to come
back on a question
I wanted to just Express that uh one
person in my family was one of those
officers that had to go around telling
people not to drop litter it's a very
difficult job very difficult I wouldn't
like to stay any of these shows but he
was someone that done um
self-defense so he knew what to do
exactly I do hope that those officers
have an experience or very or
experienced in that to keep their
distance from
as it has been said done in the past
with with
offensive weapons that's all I'm asking
is that it has to be
they have to be really good at doing
what they're doing and know what they're
where they are that's
that's the difficult part and I'm
pleased to see that that is going to
happen as well thank you yeah no they're
all very they're qualified and what I I
didn't want to get into too much detail
but as part of the the process and the
contract with national enforcement
Solutions and it says until they are
National so they're very well versed at
doing this we have an officer that is
our kind of manager of of the contract
who it will be based locally so that's
all we're always really really good
thank you
um are there any more questions from
members
thank you um I've got a question uh
Tracy and this National enforcement
Solutions
um as somebody who's been content on a
Sunday morning to Rifle with rubber
gloves on through a fly tip for evidence
are they 24 7 this company
no they won't be 24 7. I'd love them to
be 24 7. but they work alongside our
officers so what they're as available as
as much as we can and you have a
separate litter team than a flight
tipping team so there's one particular
individual that will investigate all of
the fly tips and quite often you'll find
as I'm sure we will they will be from
out of borough
um but yeah they're very good at
investigating the fly tips I have to say
and they will follow through on duty of
care okay well we'll have a conversation
around whether they're out of borough or
not or District we should say here
um offline but
um it would be good to know we could
find a resource at weekends because that
is the prime time that we have the fried
tips I might be able to reassure you
because one of the things that we did is
that the individuals that will go out
and see the fly tips of those that are
clearing it which are different set of
people so we do a toolbox talk and we
give them the powers on how to gather
the information from the fly tip whilst
they're clearing it and then that's then
passed on so they don't necessarily have
to be there at the time that it's found
it's about working alongside other
officers within the council so that the
evidence is gathered appropriately
because one of the things we found in
the early stages is the wonderful guys
from our Depot we're like it's enough to
have a Depot they will go out and
they'll remove the fly tip and they'll
just go plonk on the officer's desk of
what they thought the the evidence was
and and so there's some education around
that but yeah it happens
very seamlessly I can assure you and
what I meant by outer Barrel was that
the perpetrators
um are usually from out of borough
um and that's what I was referring to
the possibly not
um
just a couple of points um
one of the members mentioned that it had
Angela Law's name in this report what
page was that sorry
last page
um right so that needs to be amended
yeah at the time she was still in post
but that will be amended thank you and
also there is
one error on page 7.7 3.7
uh one two three fourth lying down on
that paragraph it reads uh custodia
sentence of six months or more or
criminal offenses
um is that
um correct should it read as that
custodial sentence of six months or more
or criminal offenses relating to the
underage it's just seemed that the or
more might have been a typo or is that
correct no that's correct it has to be a
minimum of six months or more okay yeah
just an easier just leave the comment
around there then I think just a little
bit of grammar
um
so uh members there is one
recommendation a paragraph uh 10.1 on
page 7.2 of the report that the
council's annual usage of Ripper be
noted is this noted members
thank you
um Tracy you're welcome to leave
then thank you very much for your report
okay members agenda item eight terms of
reference of the council's flood forum
um
3.7
minimum sentence
and it says maximum sentence
it'll be minimum so that needs Amendment
as well same page 7.7 3.7
thank you very much councilor Mrs goodin
for pointing that out
lovely
we've got that haven't you son yeah
thank you
um members I would like to invite
councilors Lamborn Milne Stanley uh to
present their verbal update on the task
and finished groups review of the terms
of reference of the council's flood
Forum I know both myself and also
councilor Mr efty have been part of this
um who who would like to lead on this
if you'd like to go and first thank you
okay
um I I was asked to set five questions
um concerning flood management and and
asking if there's any proactivity or
resilience to deal with that and about
our relationship with the statutory
bodies that actually have
responsibilities which is Essie County
Council anglian water British waterways
board and I got the information for the
questions really from the typical
questions that other District councils
are asking up and down the country
and the reply was generally we are more
reactive in dealing with flooding after
it happens because I had a reply from
Jeff Stacy who who deals with
emergencies but having said that
in his reply and this is probably quite
heartening
he said they had a meeting on the 10th
of November and things were had been
delayed because of the amalgamation
would bring well the administration with
Brentwood and Rochford the
transformation program it was agreed to
put forward the case for the appointment
of a new member of staff to lead on
drainage and flood prevention
and the issues
concerning both councils and that
proposal is currently being developed so
though at the moment
they do something after somebody's house
has been flooded that there are issues
with repairing and owners and and
getting them to do anything their issues
um with
um sustainable drainage and
modernization because some of the old
parts of the district have got the
old-fashioned sewer and not separate
surface water drainage but they're large
capital projects so he did Cover each of
the questions quite well I won't Wade
through them all but I can send you
uh the response probably easiest to do
rather than read it all out
um so we we looked also at the flood and
Water Management act 2010 but he wasn't
familiar with that but other councils
have been asking about that
um and the related flood and Coast
Coastal erosion risk because we've got
you know we've got Seaside we've got to
look at it and we've also got River
estuaries so uh that side of the
district although I'm from Rayleigh
doesn't affect me too much but it does
if you're up on the Crouch you know
um so there we are so um he also says
that he wasn't aware how RDC updates
flood risk management as a major
consideration under the national
planning policy framework because one of
the questions was in view of the
building that's going on
and the fact that they have to put
surface water storage tanks in and all
the rest of it in the modeling and a
particular concern and we did turn it
down was the building that was proposed
off the Eastwood Road in what is a
surface water Valley drainage Valley I
was quite worried about that as all the
ward councilors were but it was said by
Essex County Council that was going to
be okay you know I wouldn't like to live
downwind of it so there are issues there
but at least we're looking at some
proactivity and the suggestion we will
have an officer to deal with it so what
we need to do is follow through because
we've got the overview
and now we can see if that takes place
and what the results are and of course
the good news is we have got a flood
Forum which is
rather excellent
members would be grateful if those um
questions could be circulated
um councilor Mr fdiu feeding back on the
working group as well yes I can feedback
on the working group we met on the 15th
of November
room in South Street about an hour and a
half we come we've sort of worked around
the flood Forum what we find is good
about the platform what we find is not
so good about the platform
um so a little bit of what come from
that
the platform is organized by RDC since
Inception I think it's 2012 I think it
was something like that
I'm not 100 sure on that we're supposed
to bring all the statutory up
um organizations together to see who
takes responsibility for what type of
flooding and we'd like them to
um
so this includes Essex highways
environment agency is its County Council
and RDC members of the public also
invited sometimes
um so our recommendation sort of
they're still percolating and coming
together but what we got so far is
keep an action log on what's Happening
with ongoing progress reports
uh gender items arising for minutes so
stuff that doesn't get forgotten
I know they will have limited budgets
but it seems to be they seem to get
quite a lot of console consultations so
where possible try and use local
knowledge
um planning process of RDC
um this has been RDC planning whose
planners and negotiate with developers
how to how maintenance is going to be
carried out on ditches attention ponds
and and who will be responsible going
forward so we'd like that to be
that's more RDC with the planners
that's more or less what we've got we
we've got like a wish list and we're
sort of running it down which is
actually feasible and possible and
affordable
thank you councilor FD so that's a
verbal report members and the working
group will be coming forward at a later
date
I don't have other questions in this
item
yeah
um councilor Stanley just a question on
this one it's not a question because I'm
on that yeah
um
there's
it's got to we are trying to
evaluate where flooding is in our area
Rochford and Rayleigh especially there
are many aqueducts and and and
other areas where it is considered by
Essex County Council the suds committee
if you like that it doesn't flood in
rightly well unfortunately looking at
the map and we are looking at areas
where it does potentially and will give
rise in the future this is the point the
point that I'm trying to make is that
this committee or this working group we
are looking at future references because
of the climate change that we're
expecting and we could see raw if
underwater completely underwater it will
be like a village
floating sort of thing you get a boat
instead of a car and all this sort of
thing so these are the things that we
are really looking at for the committee
and the recommendations that we will put
to full counts of to this uh overview
and scrutiny committee to put to full
Council there's there's lots of things
in there that will just formulating and
and I'm sure Council FD will agree that
it is quite a large he's going to be
quite a large bit of work for the areas
that we do we've not only radio and
Rochford but we're talking about
wakering as well in in coastal uh
barriers if we're going to put those in
and that sort of thing so there is a lot
to be a lot to be done yep thank you
very much thank you very much councilor
[Music]
celestion not forgetting um the impact
of future developments that needs to be
um considered and anybody else got any
comments or questions on the report from
the working group
and just to say um Echo councilor
Stanley's word it is a huge job that
you're taking on that working group so
if there's other fellow members who
would like to help or dip in
um to offer some assistance to speed
that task through that would be greatly
appreciated
if there is anyone that is really sort
of concerned about flooding in their
area for do let us know what what the
area is of concern to them and and I'm
sure we will put that on our document uh
later to be expressed here thank you
thank you
members agenda agenda item number nine
is
um now have you reviewed that because it
will not be in your papers
I have it here in front of me would you
like me to go through each item
individually
yep love
Okay so
I can read this out
um
key decision
um document
422 voluntary sector grants allowance to
agree the funding allocations for the
voluntary sector grants popped February
23 is the date for the decision to be
made documents are submitted to the
document
um
make it who's a lead officer on that is
Tracy Lilly sorry
next one is the community investment
plan to agree the community investment
plan setting out level of drawdown and
how this will be used decision maker is
the executive
um and then it's got portfolio holder
for communities and health
the date or period within when that
decision will be made is January 2023
anybody indicating note
so this is really more for noting but if
you've got a question please do raise
your hand
um key decision uh document
um the next one is the mill arts and
Event Center Rayleigh to agree the
future operating model of the mill and
events uh Center Rayleigh decision maker
executive portfolio holder for housing
assets and Leisure
the date for this decision to be made is
January 2023.
next one is the council slasher
um service provision to agree the
process to establish the future of the
council's Leisure service provision from
April 2025 the decision-making executive
portfolio holder for housing assets and
Leisure
the date or period within the decision
to be made is December 2022 so this this
month
and I think that is it
no questions
okay members
um
next is a gender item 10 the work plan
members you have got the work permit in
your pack
has anybody got any questions on this
work plan
please indicate
no questions
don't take time to go through it
no one's indicating so that is the last
item on the agenda members so at
2029 the meeting is closed thank you
very much